general solution this is that solving
piece that's what solutions are now we
have been soul may freedom edge
equations for so long that we've kind of
forgotten like the bane fundamental
problem that comes up when you try to
solve something like say and we can all
write this you solve something like one
mr. I 10 X is equal to 1 right there are
some values of X then solve this
equation to satisfy it they have the
solutions right the problem with every
tree in metric function sine cos 10 SEC
Kosek but every single one of them is
periodic that's the American job because
they are periodic that means if you can
find any solution through any
trigonometric equation that means there
must also be infinitely many solutions
to that I mean if you find one solution
you just have a look at the community
you just add that up if two creates two
Pines just as your minor periods pilot
three you should add pilot three will
keep on getting more solutions so in
order to sort of bring this problem down
to size
won't you start at looking at problems
like this we tacked on an extra bit of
information
to make an eligible management we said
look they just solve it everywhere this
solve it in a little spot and if we call
of course we call that that's a big
incision right what's a typical domain
restriction
here it's not too hot
that is a very ko adminstration in fact
it's by far the first corner stranger
right
probably Nixon might be negative PI to
PI but you get the idea that principles
the same
Robin sing the whole all real values X
you're now saying look at hey well let's
just look at this little pot and all the
solutions there and for this is this we
would probably say there's a acute angle
ourselves it's what is the ginger sauce
and you say okay we'll call this the
base ego the acute angle the first
solution to this and then you might do
some lucky around with quadrants all
stations to central and central or you
might draw a graph did you say okay well
there's one more solution for not to
apply and in this case that other sushi
and you say cool I got two solutions
from generally looking for
however I'm doing really badly today but
the tension applies now that we know in
verse 3 we have the tools to say you
know what I don't need this anymore
right I can take advantage of the
patents that are sort of inbuilt to
every function and I can give you not
just one not just two not even handful
and give you all the solutions for once
so in other words rather than the
solution in a specific domain specific
solution has we mean by general solution
can you say to me can you give me some
kind of expression that tell me all of
them at once so to help you develop into
this three is one person one because of
opportunity
we're gonna need some pictures okay so
this is where we have this very very
wide antis I've slightly modify the
question okay and now no longer saw in
ten x equals one in a specific domain
and so we get generally everywhere so
that's why I've drawn so many principles
clearly I'm going to have a whole bunch
of solutions and the solutions to this
equation are represented by the points
of intersection between why it was 10 x
and y equals one that's bent and xt-1 so
you can see I've got a whole bunch here
and we're going to actually label a few
of me there's so much stuff here we
could just you know crap this whole
diagram out this whole packaging plant
with some labels well I don't do that I
just want to draw out the important
details now like we said as we already
point out but first solution is pile on
for now just a quick hit right you
should know where that is like you know
when you're drawing your y equals what
like if 50 to say I'm just gonna pour
this anywhere but because you know the x
equals plan for should be a solution if
you want to go ahead and do this
accurately you don't weigh the first
acetate is what is the first asset of
yes
you'd say x equals pi inclusive
generally I mean I say the first deposit
direction with my so if this
is platitude if you're gonna pile on for
half way there right so that's why I've
drawn this guy
there's my first solution
the brass
so we've got our first solution pine for
you can see what the next solution is
but before we get to that I just want
you to see now that you have this
picture you don't have to fuss about
with it in quadrants and arbitrary
acronyms and echo things you can just
see all of the solutions he had all of
these points of intersection and if
you've done a decent job with no crap
then you'll see every pi radians you're
getting a new solution why is it PI
ranches my plants at the minute that is
how often tam repeats right so you can
see from perform if you go forward pi
radians right that's what lands you on
the next solution which we already
identified which is five pounds for
you can go again another pi radians
right and your comes with a third
solution which is going to be your
adding four pi or so you're going to get
that belly on for and not just for words
but you can also go backwards right it's
the same period so if I subtract PI what
will this solution over he be - yeah
negative 3 PI Laura
yeah ok you could go another time
yep negative seven PI on phone and on my
graph I fitted one more solution on
which is
oh okay
so there is a clear pattern here we
could take advantage of right you don't
have to think about Oh pretend is
positive in the first and third
quadrants
you're just saying look tasty right
every pi radians if I have a solution he
is the first one right I can get every
other solution the entire domain all
real values of X just thought that one
just go backwards and forwards both of
us apply that's why I have to say okay
so here is my general solution for 10 X
equal 1 and right to end I'm going to
say X is equal to like what equals to
the hell
and I'm gonna say I start with pine
floor that's why my base solution my
first
and then all you have to do is add on
like one client replies I plan or you
can add on if you like negative punches
apply that that works fine a good
directions so I'm gonna call that and
play right where n is an integer
okay so this is the general solution for
tennis it was one it's not just one
solution to its every solution that
exists you just have to put in values of
N and you'll get all of these for
example you could put in N equals two
and that will give you this solution
over here
this is your n equal to zero you're
ready here's one it is equal to two and
you've got your any closer negative one
negative two maybe three different
values of n you'll get every single one
okay so on top of this I'm gonna say in
a slightly different way I had a notable
succinct way and you'll see is far more
frequently rather than starting from the
base angle right we know an addition is
let me do if I can put this any order I
like so more frequently you will see it
written like this right in other words
just start from your multiples of Pi
stop from 0 to PI and then come forward
a little bit whatever distance you want
will stop from 5 pi over here is where
okay I think go forward
and then to say this part in a slightly
more succinct way because you're going
to be saying it a lot I'm going to put
this restriction on in and we'll you
might remember now though that funny
curvy looky
sorry goes this way means is an element
it belongs to the step and belongs that
set off and this is the symbol that we
used to be integers so that's it that's
the general solution box now you might
remember I said oh now that we have
these must read at last we can actually
launch it to this okay where is inverse
tree in this process of fighting the
general solution yeah fantastic
where is powerful comfortable then I
think the values I are this is an easy
one to solve right we know this value is
that exact value so we don't have table
head X that first solution is tan
inverse of 1 which of course is Pinal
fork
but if we went solving 10x equals one
who sold me some orchid value like 10x
equals if it didn't need you like 350
0.1 any value right we're gonna have to
appeal ten minutes because there won't
be like a nice exact value we take K
inverse off whatever okay so in this
case with water that's why you got a
nice one so therefore we can put a box
around this this is the way generally
speaking not just for this question is
this general solution but for tears x
equals and you can have any closer there
you like in a real closet i should say
if your soulmate 10x equals case the
general solution is x equals n pi plus
whatever solution that you have there
for 10 inverse of that constant in this
case it was worth
and don't forget you introduce this and
business straight so you need to say
it's important it does have to be a
whole number right it has to be an
integer you can't have like 1/2 pies you
can only have one or two or three or
Junaid you need 100 that part's really
important ok it's critical to the
that is the general solution Fitz